[Music]
hey what's going on everybody for first
we feast I'm Sean Evans coming at you
from the fifth annual New York City
hotspot Expo which is one giant spicy
hot sauce Illuminati meeting all the
movers and shakers are here shift turn
and Korean is Carolina Reapers I can't
wait to see somebody cute on the stage
of doom
let's go mix it up and then bring it in
back Oh be careful all right so the
first stop on our journey is with Steve
Seabury who is notable for a couple of
reasons one because he organized the
expo today we only employ the best
console makers through the show but too
because it's a man behind high river
robe so he had the place in hot ones
Laura can you talk to me about the expo
for a second kind of a crazy scene here
this is a most badass hot dog that's in
the world it is a player concert people
from all over the country are flying to
New York City to get the best hot sauce
we're not having to flip up making this
hot sauce in a bathtub come in here I'm
trying to pander the stuff to everyone
these are the top top guys in the
industry this is a not a typical food
festival not for the weakest apart this
is a Pantera flavor contour pedal to the
metal let's get crazy let's drink some
beer and get our [ __ ] asses lit up
and I'm ready to ride the Hot Sauce
waves Steve it was nice meeting you but
I got a lot to do today
I say put on that life preserver and
ride that wave dude
John Dewey from DEFCON here and you know
the hot sauce community it always seems
the kind of border on the fetish
community and new country needs to be
straddling that line yes I'm very odd
that oddball quality I don't want you to
take this the wrong way I kind of leads
into the sauces it's just roll abnormal
and he wasn't any hot sauce
manufacturers something wrong with them
genetically there's something wrong with
them and then do you keep like a little
vial on you or something for ya your
legend precedes do a little bit wait
what is this thing uh this is called the
DEF CON 0-8 pounds of scorpion pepper
put it into about a quarter of an ounce
it's really nasty stuff great heart
great apart explore your friends uh if
you have a roommate you don't like take
a food injector put into his toothpaste
when it gets up under the gums it's
really really painful
put in the shampoo oh let the whole body
feel it it's been figure rating but
anyways if s20 hits this nasty
[Music]
the big moment we're about to meet chip
he is looking like the king of the hot
sauce Expo that he is I know that you're
too humble to admit it but a lot of
people think of you is kind of a hot
sauce industry gatekeeper kind of a
puppet master kind of a guy who makes
the hips happen the la read of hot sauce
what cooks key what's the secret to
making a successful hot dog I think the
secret is that you've got to do
something it's not being done okay that
matches food and that you're passionate
about
and I know that you're too humble to
admit they're stupid but you're
obviously far and away the best drop me
and I'm a pro today from the pants to
the shirt to the chicken hat but I don't
know that's the most important accent is
the hot sauce Hall of Fame ring there
you go there you go I pull it off damn
right hey Ella great day I think that my
favorite part so far has just been
running up on hot sauce makers that are
on the show and just saying what's up so
this is kind of fitting for the first
week these hot ones fans out there you
might know Noah from Heaton as' he's
been on the channel before and then this
is chef Jacob from home boys who
actually makes the hot one sauce an
interesting time for all of us because
it's been exactly a year since we
launched the hot one sauce and it's
crazy too because the channel had maybe
thirty three thousand subscribers when
we did it now we're pretty close to a
million then really transformative I
think for all of us you know seeing this
come to fruition and the if you look at
the reviews on the site and the feedback
that I get people love what you're doing
they love the sauce and I love it and I
mean if people are so dedicated they're
emailing me questions about you guys
like I got a Ford that one over there
I got to get back from your kitchen I
guess there's nothing left to do but
just start signing some bottles
nonetheless let's do it
give the people what they want Wow a
bottle signed by Jacob and Shawn that
were you doing on value at a $12 you
can't afford it go to my personal
collection alright so we here was then
and bid from torchbearer and they're
responsible for the zombie apocalypse
bottle where the hell did the name come
from basically whenever we come up with
a new sauce he and I split split a
bottle on a big meal tommy was the last
of the super hogs we get that way is
that after it was done his tongue was so
swollen he could talk I was stumbling
around like a zombie guy and right when
I saw his he's like my cookbook without
a thought and it just that's the light
bulb yeah a stroke of genius hair on her
hair
[Music]
when you run into bravado spice go where
you run into the guys that makes a
blueberry ghost pepper you just got to
say what's up my husband dude thanks I
make you see brother when you see
celebrities react to the hot ones
thoughts do you have any favorites is
there any sense other than any that
stand out laughter which straight the
right out of the bottle love it
what's fruity but in a different more
fermented way definitely did can I keep
this poem in my purse Russell Brand's
reaction is pretty good it's pretty much
what I wanted I was kind of banking on
him clean Russell Brand about it to the
clean I like it Padme like yeah Pat
pesetas up [ __ ] your mouth up ha yeah
yeah fantastic
this is getting hot mm-hmm
this is just out right I'm gonna [ __ ]
your mouth I'll call ya I'm not sure if
you're aware of this or not but on our
show blares Megadeth waffles liquid rage
is the last wing
we've had many celebrity guests get very
upset with Blair and say mean things to
Blair on camp Blair [ __ ] you Blaire okay
who the [ __ ] is Blair he'd have to be
like a jerk-off dude to make something
like this Megadeth sauce with liquid
rage oh yeah that's the selling point
Blair look he does he laughs you say
[ __ ] you Blair and Blair left so we're
gearing up for the main event it's the
atomic wings of doom competition 12
Psychopaths are going to take the stage
some amateurs some seasoned vets they're
going to clean some wings and then
they're gonna crown a champion
[Applause]
[Music]
it's easy to joke around but you were up
on that dangerous of the heavy hitters
the guy that you got into a wing off
with I think he's like a Carolina Reaper
ET champs he actually beat me two years
ago so this is sort of a comeback story
for me very much a McGregor Diaz sort of
you know you could have given up when
you lost a couple years ago moving is an
event I've done in the spicy game but no
no got back in the gym you went on the
speed bag and then you beat him at his
own game
in a wing off winners don't quit those
kids out there like that spicy meat that
that's also that hot sauce to enjoy it I
say go after it let's do it
enjoy a rebel in that place and maybe
one day to be a wing thing like me
that's a very exciting moment I finally
got my face to face with smokin and
curry some [ __ ] bud pepper company so
you sent us the Carolina Reapers that we
ate with chili clouds both times
[Music]
we'll see reactions that you had are
just unbelievable we actually run it at
the store down in South Carolina all the
time have you ever met chili Klaus yeah
yeah he came down and spent a couple
days that are far item face-first in the
dirt you know literally knocked them
down to the dirt I've heard that you can
just pop these things like they're
nothing no I feel the pain like earlier
today I just took a nibble off the
bottom of one it got you know I got the
goose bumps I got all that stuff a
little bit of France but the burn was
being tastic I had to walk around the
block a couple times you know you get a
little high and it's like oh no what am
I going to do now people want to talk to
you and you're like just shut up okay I
got a walk that's the big thing like
when we do them I always tell people
like get the cab ready like we're going
to shoot this I'm going to give you some
stuff to work with and then I'm getting
it out of there no one talked to me for
a couple hours can you speak to the
competition and what sorts of things
even maybe you have up your sleeve well
since I released the Reaper
there hasn't been any other peppers that
have tested anywhere close and the
Reapers actually got hotter on average
over the last you know four years it's
up to about two four four million if
someone happens to come close maybe gets
close to the record I'll release
something new too so you know flag them
down to remind them who's boss yeah that
time is bought that's exactly it
the response has been very positive
sometimes I think like do these hot
sauce makers who like being on the show
do they not like being on the show here
we get to see it in real time so it's
very exciting very rewarding
come on I'm going to trauma come on I'm
not calm ha no way I know what that does
to my day I know is that done to my
night I'm I got a flight tomorrow I'll
do one looking at you're a sick man I am
a sick man